Hello, hello!
Bagging Pierce is the key
to our proxy defense,
and the defense is life itself.
See you at Plymouth Rock.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
JESSE ARMSTRONG:
In episode five,
when they visited Pierce,
is-- an interesting thing to me
is that
the Roys are somewhat outsiders,
right?
Logan Roy is Scottish
and Canadian,
and his family are one part
of the media.
And I guess the Pierce's
represent the Peabody,
Boston Brahmin,
the longer heritage
in the business.
Welcome to Turnhaven,
our city on the hill.
ARMSTRONG:  That clash
of cultures appealed to us.
And Logan wants their respect
and he also wants,
at some level, to destroy them.
I suppose you've been waiting
for this moment
for quite a while, haven't you,
greedy guts?
ARMSTRONG: Cherry was fantastic
to work with.
She's obviously something
of a legend of stage and screen.
She had that formidable quality,
and she let's the ludicrous,
you know, sort of life,
happen around her in a good way.
-NAN PIERCE: Cheers, everyone.
-ALL: Cheers!
(APPLAUSE)
ARMSTRONG:
In that dinner party scene,
the tough thing for Shiv is...
she has always been able to see
how expectations and pressures
on her siblings have kind of
bent them out of shape.
Any thought given to whom
you might handover the keys?
Why madam, that is very forward.
And you're no fun.
It's easy to see that happening
to other people,
but when you're the one
under the microscope,
you can find yourself behaving
in ways-- irrationally, unsmart.
Oh, for fuck's sake, Dad.
Just tell them it's gonna be me.
There's lot's of times in life,
aren't there,
when it's easy to be the one
watching and saying,
"That's foolish."
But when you're suddenly
under the spotlight,
you find yourself making
unwise decisions.
My dad doesn't really like
to be pushed.
Also, there could be
repercussions.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪